[Music]
i'm jessica chomich morales and i'm a
neuroscientist at the mcgovern institute
at mit
i use a brain imaging technology called
functional magnetic resonance imaging
more commonly known as fmri to see which
regions of the brain become active when
we do certain things
studying the brain is a passion that
arose from being an only child to
immigrant parents i grew up observing
how cultural differences can drive
differences in behavior
my family is from asuncion paraguay this
really oddly shaped country in south
america
i'm producing a neuroscience podcast in
spanish to bring free and valuable
information to the hispanic community i
know from my own experience that there
are not many hispanic people in the
sciences and on top of that most
scientific content is available only in
english
but i'm going to change that
my podcast is called me ultimate
which translates to
my last neuron
i hope to inspire the next generation of
hispanic neuroscientists with this
podcast
[Music]